okay so that this is the closest we
could get to Fionna and cake here not
not quite the Hat and not quite the
sassy cat Ellie he's very sassy oh is it
okay be but not ashy but um we can
change that
you know just how committed are you to
the joke we can make he or she come on
you'll like worst isn't he kidding
doesn't she like you call me here for
that so okay yeah we gotta keep talking
then all right so this is Fionna and
cake this is like the big episode that
like everyone always talks about and now
I see why there's only two because that
that ending was hilarious
even when they were starting to lead up
to it I wasn't catching on I thought
maybe it was like a parallel dimension
or they're gonna like that one to the
land of oh and just find out there
happens to be this polar opposite where
I didn't catch on at all cuz the rest of
it but for those who whatever need to be
reminded that this is an episode where
every gender is switched around even in
the opening which took me a second I
like doing a double take on that imagine
the people that like saw this for the
first time not knowing it was coming
they're just like honestly that's how I
was cuz I heard a bit about that there
was an episode oh where they changed the
genders and I'm like okay but I didn't
know when it was or what it was called
so when it came up I was like okay wait
wait whoa wait what's going on here I
like why mal I like it when it can just
throw you into something like now I mean
the show is so good at doing that anyway
and it's a start up you got Fionna and
cake and cakes Kat now and all the
genders are reversed and it's Prince
Monica oh no Prince I got a whole
gumball yeah which I like and he wants
to invite
Fiona to the gumball would let's get
that works um and and as a date not as a
friend and she's so excited she gets all
dressed up they sing a nice romantic
song together and it's finally clarified
because in the beginning he's a bigger
tease than bubblegum office I was
just like oh my god like I own that
bubble gum this guy's horrible and so
finally it looks like he's committing
her and everything going out date and it
turns out it was actually the ice queen
the whole time
voiced by Azula that's awesome and they
have a fight at the end and again the
prince is gonna ask her out to go on a
date that she's like now I think I'm
good cuz I really get the hots for the
Ice King and then they go on and on
about the ice cave turn so it's all just
a fan fiction that the Ice King is
written well Finn and Jake are trapped
and it just ends right there and I I
love that twist because nothing about
this episode would indicate it's that
you know at least by the Ice King that's
what's so great about it
and it's just a it just makes the Ice
King scarier
yeah thank you wants to see like Finn
and Jake as girls and then he wants to
see like whatever's love of his life
bubblegum as a boy now it's really weird
it just makes it all the more unsettling
um though maybe naively creepy I don't
know or me that's just the ideas you're
not supposed to think about it at all um
but yeah I really liked it I liked what
I loved gender roles
stuff I like it when things are switched
around and they mix it up it just to see
what happens and stuff so I liked seeing
all the different things that they do
you know I liked her you know saving him
I liked him being you know dressed up in
pink and stuff it was Neil Patrick
Harris right so ya know I thought that I
thought that was great and yeah I'm
trying to think
the
unicorn la monochromicorn yeah I I wish
he talked cuz I loved that design but I
I know that's the joke is that he's
haven't talked enough like that but I
just looked at this thing I'm like oh my
god this thing looks so cool you know I
wanted to talk I'm trippin what else and
what was the mail Marceline Marshall Lee
Marshall you don't get his name until
the next time okay I'm so curious how
they how they do a second one if it's
just another fan picture if they do
something else I don't know buddy it was
I thought was really fun and I like
seeing the switch right I liked the
female J guile I thought they got a real
good voice for her too mm-hmm
plus I love the fact that a lot of what
cake did is what cats do the puffing
tail with the catnip the eyes get huge
and then you should just see her going
yep with the bag yeah no I did all that
stuff I thought was really really good
um I just felt it was just good it's
just a good episode I had a good good
twist at the end everything so uh what
about you guys I love it
I absolutely love it actually um when
they first showed it to me again when I
first started watching Adventure Time I
didn't watch it in order I would just
watch random episodes just as it came on
or whatever and they're like hey look at
this this was different and I'm like
that makes no sense but it's kind of
cute and it makes you know and watching
it the second time I love it even more
no more Fionna
I love it even more now that I've been
watching it and they're trying to get it
and I know who everybody is it's not
just like this random like oh that's
kind of cute and weird
um I think Neil Patrick Harris does a
great job as as gumball and it's not
because I've been in love with him since
he was in Doogie Howser Gaiman he gets
the most women every
all of them seriously look at like his
track record Barney Stinson I Met Your
Mother
he's sleeping with women on a consistent
basis I've never seen a gay man get so
many women ever I get a feeling a lot of
gay men would get so many women if they
were yeah I'm just saying though I know
he's great I look I love him I really
like because there were some moments
where you could tell it was him but I at
the same time it wasn't so much and for
me especially because I'm a huge mph fan
you know I kind of lose the oh it's NVH
and and he kind of becomes gumball and
that's I thought that was really neat
really nicely done I love cake because I
love cats and I love that cake is voiced
by the sassy old lady we think she sound
Oh Amen that was an older show was it
okay I think that's a tease if I
remember right she sounds like an older
lady to me and and that part where she's
a gonna help Fiona with the dress and
it's on like all I mean let me help you
I will take care of this it was well and
it's still very cute it's still very
Jake to which I like you know it's all
the stuff it and I like I guess I like I
like episodes I can kind of show that
it's like you know they're just
obviously big difference between men and
women and how they act and stuff like
that but it's like there's not I don't
think there's as many as like some
people build it up like you know oh you
can't write a man Thea you know those
same way you write a woman stuff like
that it's like the stuff a you know is
cool and funny and interesting is
something that is that all around I
don't think there's always like oh you
have to write a woman this way you have
to write a man this way instead I think
there's a lot of proof to that I'm in
this I think the only thing where I did
say well that looks a little weird
because they don't establish no strength
or whatever is when she's carrying the
France I'm just like I don't think she
has the upper beyster like everything
else I'm just like no I didn't I think
this works by and I think it's just as
funny I thought it was interesting that
I
King makes ice queen like super evil
super I mean she's like really nasty
evil as opposed to ice king who's kind
of kind of like evil but a bubbling
idiot evil I mean ice queen is hardcore
because ice king is not when people
write phone thick they make their
character whoever they are the badass of
it that's true
that thick is I I don't know ever
nothing else in this indicates with the
exception of the ending they're like Ice
King wrote it I know I don't know that's
the intent i saw her about as you know
like the Ice King usually I guess you
know there wasn't as much the
patheticness okay I mean she was with
her but but she does about as much nasty
stuff as the ice you does but but you're
in but there was a curator serious about
it I was guessing there was no there's
no element to feel sympathy like you
have with the Ice King though even again
you kind of get to know the ice can
think we have like an episode in there
um a traffic I think the two I would
like to see I they may even get a line
but it's like I'd like to see just how
they would have done them is the male
MRSA way I think it wasn't funny at the
mayo treats runs and love how they did
that well tell you this and people you
can complain all you want on the forums
yeah
no hair we even know you're that say I'm
not complaining now Marshall Lee does
come back for the second one and he is
voiced by the guy from community uh-oh
who's also a rapper I guess which I just
found out Thank You Christopher
um childish gambino I guess this is
rapping rapping name okay so he does
appear and he does have an actual like
part tree-trunks sadly no oh that's a
shame I do well it is funny I was
telling them well and you guys would
probably get it too because he spent a
few things uh Jim Crockett has been a
few things he came Halloween dressed as
as that yes largely so as soon as he
para came as as Fiona right yeah
very very dead on yeah no it was that
you very well done it but just whenever
I saw as soon as he popped up all I
could think in my head is Jim Jim choke
is the guy who was like Creek and
tabouli FLE enough like that and that's
all I could think I'm watching it's like
oh my god Jim even for those couple
seconds
others like ed LSP had the little like
pedostache son there very briefly inches
little like stache going on I liked a
lot of the dialogue why are you always
predatoring on dudes I like that this is
Professor with my heart guts yeah I mean
like I like a lot of that a lot of the
small stuff one thing I love is that
when they had the race gumball and
monochromicorn and Fiona cake when they
get up there and Fionna and gumball fall
off and they're like oh and then it cuts
the cake and she's like why are they out
of breath we were the ones running so
good points I never actually question
that you see people riding horses and
they're like woo I'm out of breath
why you weren't running hey ya know I
like to do is fun and I think you bring
up a good point where people say oh you
can't do the same story for male and
female this is a prime example of
actually you can do that without a
problem
all you have to do is have a competent
writing staff yeah I mean it's that
there are going to be differences and
it's good to acknowledge those
differences you know k it is gonna
change things I mean but it's like it's
it's not as far off as I think people
are so afraid going to be and I think
that's just part of the fun so yeah I
really liked it I think knowing
everything apart of my head I thought
was really cool was when legitimately
kind of creepy is when the the prince is
revealed to be the eyes and just the way
it's the first the slow lab mice are
leaves bag and then just the chest opens
up and there's this other house that was
a great reveal so it's both really funny
and kind of scary at the same time so I
do want to see this really quick that
surprised me one of the cons I think it
was an amine no
Midwest cannot delete no the one right
before that ojos anime Midwest there's a
lot of people that were cause played as
you know Marshall Lee Fiona and all that
stuff there was one girl who was dressed
as Fiona in that dress I was gonna say
oh no dress I actually you know I don't
see that stand on cuz I remember that
one and I was sort of saying to myself
oh it's just like a cross thing or
something or like whatever two different
fan bases or something and she said no
it's from the show and I was really
shocked I'm like yeah shocked there's no
more of those you know what a pride
costs a frickin fortune the more I think
of some bitch she had made it well I
made some it's like to do the whatever
the Fiona it's like shirt skirt hat boom
you're pretty much no bad fat takes like
a lot of work but a lot of people put a
lot of work into it I thought there
would be more - yeah but I was I asked
her about it I'm like I you know this is
great I think it's cool and I just want
to say whoever you were I thought that
was incredibly cool that she went a step
beyond just playing Fiona she picked a
different Fiona than everyone else yeah
I wish more people would kind of do that
marceline Fiona Jake they're all the
common ones you always see them but
seeing Fiona in something with your car
I thought was really cool I've seen a
few 13 year old Bubblegum's - well now I
know that's what it's supposed to be
yeah I just see these different styles
I'm like oh oh it's supposed to be 13 so
yeah um well I love it wouldn't fans
actually go that step further and do the
things that are only in there very
briefly like there's this one guy who
was in costume I'm not gonna say very
much but he was in costume that was only
Finn in one episode and it was very
brief and everything and I'm like that's
really cool yeah cause it's like when
you come across those two or three and
like a lot of people will give when we
come across those two or three it's like
you get it you get it and it's like yes
sometimes you know Joe can be so inside
that it's still worth it just to get
those one or two that get it and they'll
laugh so hard and they'll appreciate it
all the more so it's fun stuff because
you can go to a costume store and find
Jake and Fiona or Finn and Fiona
all of that stuff but finding these
other ones that aren't in any costume
store like I look at that one I'm like
you're going a little extra further and
I think that's awesome
ya know so uh good stuff anything else
you guys got in the episode er no I just
I really enjoyed it
I really did that was yeah any question
what's that
how many people write fanfic about you
and do you read it oh my god do people
actually write fanfic about oh yeah
early oh yeah and you read it I have
only ever had one amazing gentleman he
is blushing no no it's actually the one
you would think it is because I'm like I
got to know and it's the one I want to
say it seems they're called the truth or
the special true something like that
those that know the title already know
what it is yeah I think it's like the
first gay slash pic of white B in the
video game it's it's nowhere
where can I get a copy of this oh just
type it you'll find it's like a really
famous one cuz it's like the first one
and it's really funny that's the only
one I've ever read I said okay I got a
good laugh I but no people have like set
me the other ones as I hear scarf and
blah blah blah and it's the fan art is a
lot of fun too I've been every animal
and furry and whatever you have been
every there's a ton of me is like
there's a tummy like Fiona and stuff
like that like female crazy yeah there's
a lot of fun so actually that makes it
even funnier knowing that there are a
ton of fan fictions just like this out
that's why I was asking and I was really
to an extent excited about this because
you're someone who can actually deal
with stuff like this like people ideal
what do you mean you actually come
across this stuff average folks I'm
never gonna have a fanfic written about
me don't get on it get it happen but you
know what I mean
there's our two now that should be
applied our feelings like you know you
you should know it's messed up leave you
two alone
I won't have a ticket away that's our
idea is that that's how every v-log with
you and it ends you have to be off the
couch somehow supposed to the other
couch yeah that's that's a big nice so I
turned to think what was missing
oh yeah you get ready